[Musique]
c'est dans les hauts de sainte marie que
ça ragondins accueillante familiale a
été livrée ce matin par son facteur d'un
panier fraîcheur offert par le
département dans le cadre du pacte de
solidarité d'urgence sociale la
collectivité et la poste ont mis en
place un partenariat qui vise à livrer
aux personnes vulnérables des fruits et
légumes frais une opération qui garantit
la sécurité alimentaire des personnes
fragiles qui permet également d'aider
les agriculteurs locaux à écouler leur
production
le président accompagné des conseillers
départementaux a fait le déplacement
pour cette première livraison dans le
nord-est
en fait vous savez que le département à
travers tout le réseau des assistantes
familiales des accueillants familiaux
bas nous avons le souci du bien être
aussi bien des enfants que des personnes
âgées et pour les personnes âgées en
particulier en cette période de
confinement la situation difficile parce
que la famille ne peut pas venir rendre
visite aux gramounes dans les familles
d'accueil
eh bien il nous convient de leur
apporter un petit peu de bien-être je
dirai ce bien-être passe par des petits
gestes de solidarité des petits gestes
d'amitié et bien voilà la livraison des
colis
c'est aussi un petit geste d'amitié et
je tiens à saluer ce partenariat entre
le département et la poste grâce à ce
partenariat
près de 1500 colis c'est à dire c'est à
dire 10 poissons les colis qui sont
livrés chaque semaine est bien dit quoi
s'en vont aller vers les familles
d'accueil de façon à améliorer un petit
peu line le quotidien de nos gramounes
mais aussi des enfants vulnérables
ce sont quinze mille pagny qui sont
ainsi réalisés livrés chaque semaine
1500 sont remis à la poste pour une
livraison chez les assistants et
accueillants familiaux en charge des
enfants placés à l'aide sociale à
l'enfance des personnes âgées ou en
situation de handicap
les autres sont remis au ccas et aux
opérateurs de banques alimentaires pour
une livraison personnes vulnérables
isoler les colis sont récupérées alors
elles sont acheminées sur deux lieux
deux points de distribution nous en
avons une sur saint denis et la pique de
saint denis et nous tueraient pfm de
saint louis et elles sont traitées
dispatcher après sur les pdc pour une
mise en livraison à partir du mercredi
jusqu'au vendredi la distribution à
l'heure actuelle nous livrons du
mercredi au vendredi
elle se déroulera nous avons eu une
première mission de cette semaine de
1500 caudines vendant une autre la
semaine prochaine de 1500 connaît
logiquement nous allons être sur trois
semaines déjà pour commencer nous
verrons par la suite sur la demande
depuis quatre ans madame grondin et
accueillante familiale elle s'occupe de
trois personnes âgées dont une en
situation de handicap
bah c'est ça fait très très très plaisir
parce que nous on évite de sortir vu que
c'est des personnes fragiles et
vulnérables donc du coup nous voilà on
sort presque pas donc si la bienvenue
avait des caries une salade de fruits
peut-être
et puis la réunion compte près de 690
accueillants familiaux qui recevront
leurs paniers de fruits et légumes frais
chaque semaine ainsi qu'un kit de
protection comprenant masque solution
hydro alcoolique et gand de plus les
appeler en famille recevront le
versement d'une aide exceptionnelle d'un
montant de 170 euros pendant la durée de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
[Musique]